right off the bat Alicia let's talk
about this dress tell me the process you
went through it I think if you would
have asked five-year-old let's say one
of her biggest dream was was probably to
be Belle and Beauty and the Beast
comparing it to Belle oh really
yeah that was my book what I I mean I've
done fittings before but when I actually
put it on when it was all done this
morning look at that right now look at
it already but me your dream has come
true
you're being called a breakout style
star of 2016 how does that make you feel
well I'm not just the privilege of you
know being wearing getting to wear some
dresses I don't know how many like it's
made by hat yeah is it really I mean
this is not what I woke up in you know
it's fantastic it's fun it's it's it's a
nice you know you get the opportunity to
dress up to be here with an Oscar
nomination what does that feel like I'm
at the Oscars that's how I feel looking
in you I will say this you start the
morning and yellow and hopefully you'll
end the night draped in golden Alicia
vikander